ah it's done watch one more Power
Rangers
so moving this one let's do
[Music]
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers the movie
the theatrical experience of the year
1995 that every child just had to see
and if you didn't you weren't cool
I mean yet see this movie and you had to
see it now because it's Power Rangers
Power Rangers in the 90s was an
interesting experience for me I would
often watch it before school and I kind
of snuck it because my parents weren't
like amazed with Power Rangers they were
like maybe you know a lot of punching
kicking but okay and over the years
entertainment like Dragon Ball Z became
the norm for me and punching and kicking
was okay but for a few months there they
were like Power Rangers and a little
violent Chris so I kind of thought it
was this cool thing that I was almost
kind of getting away with you know Power
Rangers has an interesting history in
America a lot of people didn't know
about this growing up but this was
originally a Japanese television show
and a lot of the American footage is
just shot to be integrated with the
original Japanese action shots so we
have a lot of stuff that's from the
original show incorporated with new
American storylines when I was a kid I
was like wow it's just so cool but now
when you look at it you're like wow all
the action stuff is so Japanese and
similar to my crush on Melissa Joan Hart
from Clarissa explains it all I had a
bit of a thing for the pink Ranger and I
think a lot of guys my age kind of did
because she was hot when I was a kid it
was like to him the pink ranger like
that's the level that's right there the
impossible you know that's that'll never
happen
the pink ranger that'll never happen
that's the the highest that my 11 year
old brain reached a pet toy and because
of the incredible popularity of the show
in America we eventually got the film
and this film is entirely American all
the footage was shot here in America
there's no incorporated Japanese stock
footage here and you know this zone is
great for about 30 minutes
and then it really starts to suck when I
watch this movie there's not a single
part of me expecting greatness I know
what I'm getting into I hope there's a
lot of kung fu sequences and hilarious
90s action music and a lot of really
terrible acting and for the first 30
minutes it's like that it's just a lot
of fun stupid scenes with Tina
rollerblading and doing insane stunts
that are clearly just for the camera
opening the movie with a skydiving
sequence that's completely unnecessary
but gracefully mostly in-camera and
fairly realistic all that stuff is the
Power Rangers stuff I like even the big
over-the-top villain hilariously
portrayed by Paul Freeman that's right
Belloc from Raiders of the Lost Ark I'm
perfectly fine with Ivan ooze and I love
all that stuff this is how I want my
Power Rangers I want cheesy guilty
pleasure garbage
unfortunately after the 30 minute mark
once the plot kicks in and they have to
save Zordon because he's dying and they
have to get zapped to some faraway
planet this movie just becomes
incredibly boring from then on and
there's really nothing else about it
that I like let's talk in depth about
this movie it opens with a three
paragraph crawl in space we've never
seen that ever in a film I can tell you
that's for sure so it's digging crew
unearths uses egg that he's been trapped
in for who knows how long and he
eventually is released and he sends all
of his cronies after the Power Rangers
now this fight scene is my favorite
scene in the entire film because
hilarious this is what I want in my
Power Rangers I just want over-the-top
insanity the music is amazing this song
is so bad it's incredible I love it
and the best part of this sequence and
when I say the best part I mean the
worst part is all of their one-liners
that are so obviously 80-yard and of
course instead of just like running
really fast
everyone in this movie has to flip
everywhere and it's amazing now it's
finally morphin time and we get to see
them in their outfits and that's where
this movie becomes a lot of fun I love
them kicking ass in their outfits I
don't give a shit this movie sucks but I
love this scene because it's amazing in
every way and every time they move
there's a sound effect i spooked it in
my intro to this video every single
movement is a sound effect pop it's
better to circle parasite
[Music]
and the wirework oh my gosh the wirework
is a thing of beauty we have so many
sequences that are just gorgeous to look
at I mean it's the best wire work since
Jet Li is the one if you've never seen
the one you're really not missing
anything maybe I'll do a hilarious idea
that one day and this scene gets even
better right about here
[Applause]
that's what I need that right there is
what I needed the entire film was like
that this would be an a-plus movie be
the best movie ever made maybe the best
movie since Citizen Kane it'd be the
greatest thing of all time unfortunately
unfortunately the rest of the movie
isn't like that but the bad guy is
disintegrating and exploding everywhere
that's what I need now here comes this
movie's first example of CGI which is
inexcusably bad for the entire film and
this is our first look at what we have
in store double whammy
let's talk about the Blue Ranger and his
stick a stinger this thing is uh you
know it's about as slow as molasses
[Music]
did you miss me I don't really see the
point of that weapon like it gives the
bad guy the biggest warning that you're
coming like Sega singer
okay I'm there whoops you already shot
me 17 times and on that same theme you
really got to love the white Ranger's
wirework powers
to demonstrate how perfect this scene is
observe the way in which the Blue Ranger
asks if its friend is okay you okay I
mean from now on whenever one of my
friends is hurt or I think something's
wrong I'm going to do that that's
exactly what I'm going to do I'm going
to do an amazing spin complete with an
over-the-top sound effect just to check
on them because that's how you get shit
done so Zordon is dying because ivan
ooze destroyed the command center so
they have to get to like a distant
planet where there's like a superpower
of some kind that they can like harness
within them to save Zordon and the only
way they can get there is by using this
how can we get in maybe if I can
download the very last asthmatic morning
gem into the transport core I might have
just enough power to get to there okay
so Ivan ooze creates a big army of birds
and the Rangers explore a distant planet
that's definitely not earth and the
hilarious bird army attacks and we get a
little bit of a fight scene where they
lose until they're rescued by somebody
now look there are a very few moments in
the film that have caused me to audibly
shout what the fuck and this movie has
one of them
[Music]
now gracefully this girl that showed up
knows everything like she just had
everything she knows at all and the
entire story everything that is the
Power Rangers have to do she knows it
she's got it all in her brain she's
perfect she has everything Rhett she's
ready she came complete with a script
for this movie and she blows like some
magical pixie dust on the rangers so
that they can discover their inner
animal spirits meanwhile the evil and
scheming Ivan ooze creates a zombie army
of all the kids parents and the kids
like yay
no school nothing let's have a big party
oh the 90s were amazing so as the Power
Rangers walk around on this planet and
walk and walk and walk and walk loose
forces the adults to dance so you know
it's a it was a good scene to watch this
movie it's at this point of the movie
really starts getting weighed down for
me because I want to see the Rangers in
their suits kicking ass with hilarious
90s rock music that's that's why I
watched this movie that that's why I
watched the Power Rangers I don't watch
for like this elongated scheming Ivan
whose plan bullshit and then walking
around on some planet discovering their
inner animal spirits I don't need that
shit let's just watch them punch things
and they disintegrate into a big puddle
of purple ooze that's what I like so
after the Blue Ranger makes a current
pop culture joke for 1995 welcome to
Jurassic Park seriously
we get a big dinosaur bone sequence
which gratefully isn't terrible mid-90s
CGI and speaking of that terrible
mid-90s CGI that I was just saying I was
glad wasn't in this movie here's this
shit
so the Rangers find the legend of the
Hidden Temple and a big battle erupts
with some rock monsters that come to
life or whatever they are and it's
during this scene that it became
incredibly apparent how often tommy is
always saving kimberly it just gets old
after a while the next they find the
Pyramid of the animal food groups and
they get their armors back yay
and then there's praying mantis bug
thingies with mid-90s CGI yay and this
is where like the movie just completely
falls apart I mean like it wasn't really
good ever but I expect a movie like this
not be good this is like guilty-pleasure
material here but this is where the
movie really falls apart where the show
had like men in suits or miniatures this
movie has a miniature we'll talk about
in a second this one is like hey let's
just use CGI for everything oh my god it
looks so terrible it looks like a
PlayStation 1 cutscene now in the TV
show but especially in this movie the
rangers announce everything they do it
take a minute to provide a stance and
then they go like you know stick a
stinger or they go it's morphin time and
they announce their animal or whatever
they are I would just love if when
everyone is standing around announcing
everything they're about to do if the
bad guy just blew them all up all right
it's morphin time
I'm the ape thing and like I said I was
going to talk about the miniature I mean
that's definitely a real train honestly
look at that it was anything convincing
in 1995 like four people in the theater
like wow look at that real train I
really don't think they were I think
they knew so as the zombie parents are
being forced to walk off a cliff the big
hero kid has to like rescue them by
spraying them with like a fire hose or
something and I don't know that whole
scene is just fucking hilarious well
this is happening the Rangers decide to
go in the path of Ivan's comics to have
that hick Ivan ooze yeah I get it
Ivan's comic Ivan ooze and of course
that happens but only because the Yellow
Ranger decides to press the
button that is for emergency use only
now what does this emergency use button
do
perhaps self-destruct sacrificing the
team to save the planet
nope we have to break a strict kind of
call for detriment what are you doing
[Music]
oh no because children kicking someone
in the balls is for emergency use only
fuck and of course since they discovered
there ninjetta animal food group pyramid
powers on that random distant planet
that definitely was not earth or a
studio backlot
they're able to rescues Zordon by
believing in themselves and suddenly
we're no longer watching a 1995 movie in
the final scene it becomes an eighties
movie
[Music]
yes the Power Rangers movie sucks it's
awful but the first 30 minutes are
exactly what I want just teenagers on
rollerblades listening to hilarious
music skydiving for no reason and
punching people in their suits and like
the creatures are blowing up and there's
purple mist everywhere now that's a good
shit that's a good shit the rest of the
movie is like bad shit so guys the new
Power Rangers movie is coming out very
soon and that's why I did this video
hopefully that one is actually enjoyable
or at least guilty-pleasure enjoyable on
the way that this film was for the first
20 to 30 minutes guys thank you so much
as always for watching another hilarious
'ti and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck menage
[Applause]
[Music]